as a war in ukraine grinds on most
russians are unaware of what is really
happening amid a new crackdown by
president putin on the few remaining
independent media outlets this morning
russian lawmakers passed a law
introducing jail terms for anyone who
publishes so-called fake information
about the country's armed forces mary
illusina is in moscow for more on the
story mary good morning to you it's
really jaw-dropping to hear what the
russian people are being told about what
is really happening
good morning yeah absolutely this law is
particularly scary because it carries a
sentence of up to 15 years in prisons
for journalists or other people who are
spreading information military
information that the kremlin deems to be
untrue at least two independent outlets
have been taken off air this week
after officials accuse them of reporting
false information which means basically
anything that is not being published by
official russian sources the kremlin
will not allow the fighting in ukraine
to be referred as an invasion or war
russian state media tightly controls the
message it broadcasts to millions of
russians repeating putin's claim that
this is a defensive operation to protect
russia against what he calls ukrainian
aggression and state-run media has also
never acknowledged the bombardment of
kiev harkiv or other cities outside the
donbass area and of course there are
many russians who see through this
message and they see through this state
reporting and they're taken to the
streets according to a russian rights
group more than 8 000 protesters have
been arrested across the country but of
course russians can still access some
independent sources via vpn or they go
online and try to search for it
this is what i'm doing a lot of
journalists do here as well but for
people who just don't know how to do
that or not that savvy uh they're being
left without a comprehensive picture of
what is going on in ukraine
mary leshina force in moscow mary thank
you very much